[Musique]
votre visite à tous Voilà c'est moi le
président
et oui mais oui il est où ton
photographe
bonjour
à l'époque ça s'appelait et ça a été
décoré pour le mariage de Napoléon III
et oui
formidable rencontre on aurait envie
d'être là pendant les 48 heures une
forme de simplicité de la rencontre
toutes les générations bien sûr des
compatriotes mais aussi des étrangers
et les chiens de l'association c'est
l'association des chiens d'aveugles
c'est le lieu où nous débattons de la
loi c'est le lieu où nous abandons la
loi c'est-à-dire pour la Mobil
culie c'est le lieu où on la vote où on
l'a rejette
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de réservation tous ceux
qui ont envie de découvrir le Sénat
peuvent le faire d'une manière spontanée
c'est l'esprit même des journées du
patrimoine je viens la rencontre du
patrimoine et je suis accueilli par le
patrimoine et le patrimoine ici c'est
pas simplement le souvenir d'un très
beau palais c'est pas simplement le
souvenir de marine Médicis si en fait
une assemblée parlementaire
d'aujourd'hui
qui travaillent dans ce palais qui
accueille des citoyens des citoyens dans
une démocratie et le fait que nous
soyons sans doute l'institution la plus
visitée et peut-être un symbole
[Musique]